hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem reverse bits and
this happens to be another problem from
the blind 75 list or list of common leak
code problems that we've been tracking
in this spreadsheet we have a solution
for the vast majority of them and i'll
be doing a few more of the binary
questions the one today we'll be doing
is this one reverse bits so this is a
good problem to kind of go over and
learn or refresh yourself on the bit
manipulation operations so we're given a
32-bit unsigned integer and basically we
want to reverse all of the bits of this
integer so like in this example this is
the integer represented in binary of
course we might not be given the integer
in binary you know that we might be
given the integer 4 which in binary we
know it looks like this and then we'd
want to reverse
all of the bits for it so basically
we would you know the reversal is going
to look something like this
right and then we want to return that
reversed integer of course we'll be
returning a one value so let's say this
is the 32-bit integer and let's just say
it's four just because we don't want to
do a super long binary integer like this
there are many ways to kind of do this
problem right suppose we declare an
output variable for result and this is
where we put the last bit the
31st bit and then over here is where we
put the zeroth bit right so we have 32
bits in the output initially we'll just
set all of these to
zero right
so we want to go bit by bit in the input
right we'll start at the ones bit we
want to get what is over here if it's a
zero or if it's a one and then we want
to take it and then put it over here in
this case it's a zero so we're just
going to put a zero over here right
basically we're reversing right we're
taking the bit from here putting it in
this spot right just in reverse order
pretty much like we would do with
reversing a string next we're gonna go
to this one put it in the next spot so
we'll have another zero here and then
we'll take a look at this one put it in
the next spot so we'll have a one here
and then since the remaining of all of
these are zeros then we're just gonna
have zero zero zero uh in the entirety
of this so uh obviously before when i
showed us just reversing these four we
ended up getting an output of one but
you can see when we actually do it with
32 bits the result changes right so and
they specifically tell us this is just a
32-bit integer so this is going to be a
pretty large integer and we're this is
what we're going to end up returning
right so it's pretty straightforward to
understand what exactly we're doing at
least with the solution that i'm showing
you now the question is how can we
actually do these operations for example
how can we go bit by bit get the first
bit get the next bit get the next bit
all the way until we get to the end
right how can we go and get each bit
well one way in binary is to just take
uh this bit right and it with a one the
and operation right logic and what we're
saying is if
since this is a zero right if we take
zero
and it with one we get the output to
that is going to be zero right which
makes sense because we want to know if
this is a zero or a one so if we end it
with a one we'll get zero if this value
is a zero that's exactly what we want if
this value is a one and we end it with a
one then we get one right which which is
good because if this is a one then we
want to get a one in the output so
that's the operation we're going to do
logic and to figure out what the bit is
now that's easy in the case we're just
looking at the ones place over here but
what if we want to look at this next
spot we want to look at the
uh two's place right and then what if we
want to look in this spot etc etc how
are we going to do that well instead of
taking this input value and then ending
it with a one we're going to end it with
a one
shifted to the left each time we you
know move a different spot in the input
right how can we shift a one to the left
that's also another binary operation so
for example if we had something like
zero one and then we do the shift
operation to the left this is a bit
shift operation if we shift it to the
left all what it does is it shifts all
of the bits to the left by one and it
replaces the one spot with a zero so in
the output we'll get this when we shift
this by one we'll get this we'll have
shifted the bit to the left by one and
notice how if we have a one over here
and then a zero over here and then we
have zeros all the way for the remaining
of it when we get the output value it's
also going to be a 32-bit integer right
but this is the only spot we're gonna
care about because the rest of the spots
are gonna be zero by default because if
we and zero with anything else we're
gonna get a zero in the output whether
you know we have a one over here or not
if we and these together we're gonna get
a zero in the output okay so that covers
how we're gonna get each of these bits
now how are we going to put them in the
output remember how initially we had a a
result that was just filled with zeros
right and we're going to start at the
beginning take every you know if we have
a one here we want to insert this one
over here if it's a zero over here then
we just want to leave the output as a
zero and then we want to move to the
next spot to the right and do the exact
same thing so we're going to follow a
similar pattern here if we had a 1 we
would take the 1 shift it to the left by
31 right because that's going to be the
spot all the way to the left we're going
to take this shift it to the left by 31
so then we'll have a suppose a 1 here
and then 0 0 0 what we want to do in
this case is not logic and but we want
to do logic or when we're trying to
figure out what to replace it with so
for example if we had a 0 here we would
want to replace this with a 1. it works
because we take 0 or it logic or it with
1 we get a 1. if we take 0 logic or it
with a 0 we get a 0. so if we had
instead of having a 1 here if we just
had a 0 here we wouldn't want to replace
this we won't want to leave it as a 0.
so that's what logic or can accomplish
for us and similar to the previous
example if we had something like this
and we were trying to logic or this
right we would want to put this one in
this spot we don't want to get rid of
this one right suppose we had already
put a 1 over here we don't want to get
rid of it so notice how if we if we if
we take this logic or it with this we
will end up changing this bit this will
be changed to a one but this bit will
stay the same which is what we want to
do because if we're gonna have a zero
here and we're gonna have zeros in every
other position the other remaining bits
are not going to end up getting changed
if they are ones they're gonna remain as
ones if they're zeros they're gonna
remain as zeros so those are some kind
of basics about bit operations logic and
logic or
bit shifting and that's kind of all you
need to be able to solve this problem in
the simplest way so now i think we are
ready to dive into the code and it's
going to be a little bit shorter than
you might expect let's declare that
result variable that i said so it's
going to be a 0 meaning all 32 bits of
it are going to be initialized as 0 and
we're going to go through every single
bit in the input end so i'm going to say
for i in range 32 because we know it's
going to be up to 32. i think we could
change the logic of this while n is
you know non-zero and we could
continuously update n i'm just going to
do it this kind of simple way so
remember the first thing we want to do
is we want to get the i th bit of n so
how can we do that well remember we were
going to take n
and it with 1 to get the i bit but if we
just end it with 1 every single time
we're only going to get the first bit
right we want to get the i bit so
instead of ending it with one well we
can take n shift it to the right by i i
don't think that's what i said in the
drawing picture i thought i think i said
we're gonna take the ones a bit and then
shift it to the left but if we actually
take n shift it all the way to the right
then in n we will have the the target
bit that we're looking for and it will
be in the one spot so then we can just
take this and end it with one and then
we'll get the result bit that we're
looking for in the ones spot so this bit
will be either one or it will be zero
and then we want to logic or it with the
output to put that bit in the output how
can we do that is it going to be enough
to just say result logic or the bit no
because if we do it like this we're only
going to be updating the one spot of
this result but we want to be updating
it in the reverse order we want to start
at the largest bit and then work our way
down how can we do that well we have
this i variable right it's going to go
from 0 to 31. so how about we do this we
shift our bit to the right by 31 minus i
so on the first iteration of the loop we
will be getting the first bit from n and
putting it in the 31 spot of the result
and the next iteration will be doing the
opposite will be getting the bit in
index 1 from n and putting it in index
30 in the output so then we're going to
keep doing that and
this is the operation we're doing and we
want to set the result equal to the
result of this logic or operation and
that is the entire code once we're done
with that we can go ahead and return the
result so this is the simplest way to do
it it is constant time big o of one
because we're guaranteed that there's
going to be 32 bits so
the solution is not going to scale
regardless of whatever the input n is as
long as it's 32 bits and where you know
the memory we're using as well is just a
single variable right so this is just an
o of one time and space solution so i
hope that this was helpful i hope it
taught you a little bit about binary
operations if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching